it was sold as oven ready but the brexit
deal is undercooked
about the view of more than half of UK
businesses who are battling
ever-changing Customs regulations
nimisha has tried to adapt she used to
get tons of fresh fruit from Europe and
sold her products over there too but the
paperwork put a stop to it all it's a
lot of work including changing packaging
lots of documentation making sure that
all the information on the packaging is
correct as well again one thing you
print incorrectly on the back of a pack
on nutritional values or something and
then all of that is gone and tens of
thousands of pounds is wasted
a conveyor belt of Customs that had her
drowning in small print is part of the
reason we saw a summer of standstill
cargo at Britain's ports post-brexit
documentation issues caused this 20-mile
queue in Dover limits on business travel
and the uncertainty over the Northern
Ireland protocol are also taking its
toll
it's been two years since the eyes were
dotted and the t's were crossed
off some are saying that longer these
problems go unchecked the more likely it
is the EU Traders are going to go
elsewhere and if they do that that's
when the damage is done
it doesn't mean drastic changes the
British Chambers of Commerce say the
foundations of the deal are strong but
it needs refining things like digitizing
trade procedures would really help in
the bigger picture we'd like to see an
agreement on agri-food so that both
sides agree our food is as safe as your
food and that we could trade without
having to have an individual Consignment
stamped with an official Veterinary seal
to show it safe it's those kind of
things that happening behind the scenes
that really make things difficult the UK
government says it's brought stability
to the UK Market instead we've removed
400 trade barriers across 70 countries
in the past two years remove tariffs on
30 billion pounds worth of goods and cut
one billion pound business costs arising
from current retained EU law
ministers on both sides are still
talking diplomatic finesse will sharpen
the deal for many businesses just want
to know when it'll start working for
them Ashner Alexander's in Kent